liebe genossinnen und genossen was immer
heute passiert es ist nicht das ende der
geschichte und das ist auch nicht das
ende der spd die doch schon so viel
schwierigere zeiten gemeistert hat als
es dieser parteitag heute tun muss
insofern frisch ans werk frohen mutes
wir werden das schon miteinander
hinbekommen
[Applaus]
aber wichtig exorbitant wichtig ist
dieser parteitag eben doch das konnten
wir in den letzten wochen alle
miteinander gut spüren denn es ist
emotional kontrovers und auch sehr
grundsätzlich geworden
lag das am sondierungs papier ich glaube
vordergründig nicht unsere debatte hat
ganz sicher nicht zum gegenstand gehabt
ob auf seite 22 im dritten spiegelstrich
noch ein bisschen was gehen muss oder ob
eine seite vorher noch einen absatz
fehlt und ob er genug substanz drin ist
aber natürlich gibt es
verhandlungserfolge wer würde denn nicht
davon reden wollen ich habe das sind
jeder das möchte ich betonen jeder
meiner veranstaltung in den letzten
tagen immer getan unsere leute ich bin
mir absolut sicher haben gut verhandelt
dass ich und viele andere in diesem saal
und auch außerhalb nicht mit dem
ergebnis zufrieden sind liegt nicht
daran dass die schlampig gearbeitet
haben sondern dass nach zwölf jahren
angela merkel mit acht jahren großer
koalition wesentliche gemeinsamkeiten
aufgebraucht sind liebe genossinnen und
genossen wo keine sind kann ich keine
aufschreiben
[Applaus]
und trotzdem gibt es diese
verhandlungserfolge die an dieser stelle
aufzuzählen noch andere übernehmen
werden
und vielleicht auch zu weit führen würde
und es tut auch mir und es tut auch uns
jusos weh dass die aussicht auf den gang
in die opposition bedeutet diese
projekte nicht umsetzen zu können
natürlich machen wir dafür politik nah
wofür denn sonst aber ich bin eben
überzeugt es geht eigentlich weiterhin
um etwas anderes und auch nach den
diskussionen mit hunderten nicht nur
mitgliedern in den letzten tagen und
wochen bin ich sicher es geht weiterhin
um die immense vertrauenskrise in
unserer partei die wahnwitzigen
wendungen und kehrtwenden unserer partei
seit der bundestagswahl haben noch mal
mehr vertrauen gekostet und es fällt
nicht vom himmel liebe genossinnen und
genossen
es ist nicht nur der vertrauensverlust
auch gegenüber der union alles schon
ausgezählt worden es ist auch der
vertrauensverlust unter uns und es ist
auch ein repräsentations problem dass
ich in diesen tagen gemerkt habe wir
wissen alle nicht die das heute ausgeht
und auch ich kann nicht sagen auch in
der mitgliedschaft ob es knapp dafür
knapp dagegen dass aber das ist knapp
ist das nehmen wir glaube ich alle waren
aber in der repräsentation die sich ja
immer auch in gremien widerspiegelt habe
ich das anders wahrgenommen mein
eindruck war je weiter ich häufig
zumindest vom willy brandt haus in
unseren gremien weggekommen bin desto
unversöhnlicher wurden die töne desto
mehr gilt die diskussion auch in einer
art wir und die ab was ich nicht
befeuern möchte was wir aber wahrnehmen
müssen als ein teil der ausgangslage
unserer diskussion und der macht mich
sehr nachdenklich dass es soweit
gekommen ist und ich stelle mir die
frage ob das eine belastbare grundlage
so einer situation für eine erneute
große koalition ist dabei möchte ich
nicht missverstanden werden wir jusos
auch wenn es uns manchmal unterstellt
wird haben nie die positionen vertreten
die große koalition mache uns klein als
automatismus
das ist nicht unser argument wir liebe
genossinnen und genossen genossen machen
uns klein und zwar durch die art wie wir
in der regierung auftreten indem wir
manchmal aufgetreten sind als wären wir
die pressesprecher dieser koalition und
nicht ihn selbst
größter koalitionspartner in der frage
wir machen und klein in der art und
weise wie wir mit uns umspringen lassen
nicht nur das mich als zwergenaufstand
habe kann ich mit umgehen mit 71 das
bedarf bezeichnet werden das ist kein
problem aber auch die art und weise die
da unsere projekte nicht umgesetzt
werden wenn wir eine kneipe werden dann
könnten wir sagen die union schreibt
seit jahren bei uns an
die haben den zettel bei uns offen der
ist so lang und das geht nicht dass wir
auf der grundlage neuen vertrag
abschließen
und wir machen uns klein durch die art
wie wir unsere programme schreiben hat
nationen dezember schon was gesagt wir
denken den kompromiss der großen
koalition weil wir um unsere wenigen
wenigen bündnisoptionen ja auch wissen
immer schon vorweg mittlerweile wir
beschneiden uns selbst in unserem denken
und das macht uns klein und das macht
unsere politischen antworten klein jetzt
sagen alle dass kein weiter so geben
kein satz wurde in den letzten wochen so
häufig zitiert aber was heißt das
eigentlich konkret womit geht es denn
jetzt nicht mehr weiter
da sind die antworten schuldig geblieben
die doch eigentlich so wichtig gewesen
werden und deswegen ist für viele in
diesem saal das zu wenig um das so
dringend notwendige vertraute das
gewünschte vertrauen schenken zu können
und es liegt auch daran wenn man
verhandlungsergebnis als hervorragend
bezeichnet und ist dann in den tagen
danach zum teil auch von den eigenen
leuten doch ganz schön zerpflückt wird
dann knabbert das an der glaubwürdigkeit
und es ändert auch nichts daran
und das ändert leider auch nichts an
dieser tatsache dass leute den wirklich
ehrenwert mouskouri ohne ironie in
wirklich ehrenwerten versuch heute wagen
eine brücke zu bauen form dieses antrags
der ja nachher auch noch einmal
vorgestellt wird und den vorhin in der
antragskommission hatten
ich bin überzeugt die brücke die diese
partei braucht um aus ihrer
vertrauenskrise herauszukommen
die muss aus erneuerungen und aus
vertrauens beweisen gebaut werden sie
wird nicht aus weiteren spiegel strichen
gebaut werden liebe genossinnen und
genossen denn an denen mangelt es uns
nicht
und es ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch
unklar nach der vielstimmigkeit der
letzten tage wie viel spielraum unsere
verhandlerin und verhandler denn
eigentlich in den möglicherweise
anstehenden koalitionsverhandlungen
sehen da gab es sehr unterschiedliche
aussagen und da hätte ich persönlich
eine belastbare einschätzung gebraucht
um auch bewerten zu können ob die brücke
die heute gebaut werden soll ob das eine
stabile sein kann oder ob das eine
schöne brücke ist die gut aussieht aber
am ende nicht trägt das kann ich statt
jetzt für mich nicht bewerten und ich
glaube es geht vielen anderen im saal
auch so wie immer wir uns heute
entscheiden liebe genossinnen und
genossen eines müssen wir uns klar
machen es wird weh tun
wer auf den punkt wartet an dem wir noch
eine entscheidung treffen können für die
wir von allen seiten applaus bekommen
dieser entscheidung wird es nicht mehr
geben
der punkt ist verpasst worden wir werden
menschen vor den kopf stoßen die er im
moment von zwei seiten an und ziehen die
einen die sagen geht in diese
verantwortung oder den anderen die sagen
lasst es sein erspart uns weitere vier
jahre hängepartie in einer großen
koalition mit angela merkel
wir können uns jetzt nur noch dazwischen
entscheiden aber wir können uns
entscheiden das ist übrigens auch
legitim micha hat dazu eben alles
notwendige gesagt das verfahren hat
immer vorgesehen das heute die
entscheidung fallen kann die große
koalition allerdings ist vor dem
hintergrund unseres dilemmas was ich
gerade versucht habe zu beschreiben
keine entscheidung sondern sie ist das
regierung gewordene sowohl-als-auch
eigentlich wollen wir ja nicht aber wir
müssen doch und das ist die
endlosschleife in der wir seit so vielen
jahren drin sind wieder genossinnen und
genossen und die muss durch
brauchen werden diese nur weh
[Applaus]
und deshalb werbe ich darum lasst uns am
heutigen tag nicht nur das risiko sehen
sondern lasst uns auch die chancen sehen
die in dieser situation liegen ich sehe
die chancen in den vielen rückmeldungen
die ich in den letzten tagen und wochen
ich persönlich aber auch die jusos
erhalten habe von hunderten es waren
wirklich tausende ohne übertreibung
menschen die geschrieben haben die
angerufen haben geht zu den
veranstaltungen kommen sind und gesagt
haben und mitglieder oder nicht ich
sorge mich um diese partei ich will sie
gerne wählen
ich möchte dass es eine starke linke
volkspartei in deutschland gibt aber ich
habe angst darum dass ihr wieder die
falsche entscheidung trifft mein appell
an diese leute die uns geschrieben haben
und die sicherlich noch viel viel mehr
sind die sich noch nicht gemeldet haben
egal was dieser parteitag heute macht
macht euch auf kommt in diese partei
macht sie zu eurer partei die
veränderungen die wir sein wollen
die müssen wir selber durch niemand
anderes wird uns diese entscheidung
abgeben
[Applaus]
macht mit bei diesen erneuerungsprozess
und wenn ihr das gefühl habt wie die da
sind werden nicht ausreichen um den
erneuerungsprozess in die richtige
richtung zu führen
dann kommt dazu und dann unterstützt uns
dabei wir werden diese unterstützung
brauchen und deshalb schließe ich mit
dem was ich zu beginn gesagt habe was
immer heute passiert es ist nicht das
ende der geschichte und erst recht nicht
das ende der spd aber das kann der
beginn einer neuen geschichte sein die
wir miteinander schreiben lasst uns
diesen aufbruch miteinander wagen und
das heißt heute einmal ein zwerg sein um
zukünftig vielleicht wieder triesen sein
zu können
heute stimmt mit nein das war der juso
chef kevin kühnert stell dir viel
beifall und jubel erntet